so this number line diagram here it
looks like I'm adding or subtracting two
numbers I'm starting with what looks
like a positive nine I'm starting at 0
and going nine units to the right so
that's a positive nine and to that it
looks like I might be adding or
subtracting something I'll have this
arrow that starts exactly at the tip of
that nine and then it goes let's see one
two three four units to the left
so I could think about this Arrow right
over here as just subtracting 4 so it
could just be nine minus four which is
of course equal to where we end up which
is equal to this 5 right over here so
that's one way to
represent what is going on as an
addition or subtraction equation but
what's another way we could start with
the nine and is there anything that we
could add to the nine that would get us
the same result
well we know when we add negative
numbers we also move that many units to
the left so you could also view this
purple Arrow right over here instead of
viewing it as subtracting a positive
four you could view it as adding a
negative four adding a negative 4. now
this is interesting because in this case
when I subtract a positive number it's
the same thing as adding the opposite of
it
now will that work the other way around
if I subtract a negative number is that
the same thing as adding the opposite
let's say we had negative 5 minus
negative 3. what is that going to be
equal to and let's think about this with
integer chips
so we could start with five negative
integer chips one two three
four
and five and now I'm going to take away
three of those negative integer chips so
I'm going to take away one two three of
them and so what am I left with I am
left over here with negative 2. so if we
think about it on a number line let me
do that right over here so if I have a
number line
and
let's say that this is 0 here and I'm
going to go negative one two three four
five so negative 5. so this is negative
5 right over here I can represent I can
start at zero and I can go five units to
the left
and I know when I subtract negative 3
I'm going to end up at negative 2. so I
know I'm going to end up
I'm gonna end up with this in a
different color I'm gonna end up right
over here
so subtracting negative 3 needs to be
the same thing as moving three units to
the right if I was adding negative three
I'd go three units to the left but
subtracting negative 3 must be the same
thing as going three units to the right
well what also is the same thing as
going three units to the right well
that's the same thing as adding three so
this is going to be the same thing so
negative 5 minus negative 3 is actually
the same thing as negative five
plus three
this purple Arrow right over here it
could it's you could view it as
subtracting negative three or you could
view it as adding the opposite of
negative three
so it looks like when you subtract a
number it's the same thing as adding the
opposite When you subtract a number it's
the same thing as adding the opposite
now that's really useful because now we
can even think about doing things with
things that aren't even integers we can
start thinking about just rational
numbers for example negative fractions
so if we take that principle we just
came up with and if we say okay well
what's 3 minus negative two-fifths
well if we take that principle that's
subtracting a number is the same thing
as adding its opposite subtracting
negative two-fifths is the same thing as
adding the opposite of negative
two-fifths so it's adding two-fifths
well we have seen this type of thing
before and we could even do that on a
number line let me do that right over
here
so let's say that this is zero
one
two
three
four
and five so we're starting here with a 3
in either case so that's three units to
the right a positive three
and so subtracting a negative two-fifths
we're saying is the same thing as adding
two fifths so adding two-fifths we are
just moving two-fifths to the right so
it's one-fifth and two-fifths so we're
just going to do that subtracting a
number is the same thing as adding its
opposite